I know you have found something a sense
of peace
okay now you are going to father told
you to go we need to destroy Buffalo how
long do I stand around correcting for oh
yeah okay oh my god he's gonna be the
better
supercalifragilisticexpialidocious
[Music]
[Music]
because you're worth it I'm dark just
the I'm doctor I can't walk it my lady
I mean yeah
[Music]
josh brolin is bringing a new iconic
villain to life
Thanos is a very complex character what
he's doing from his point of view is a
very positive thing
he's basically an eco-terrorist and he
wants to eliminate 50% of the universe
to save the other 50%
[Music]
we wanted to tell a story about a
character with a really complex and
empathetic interior life
[Music]
there's not a lot of actors that can
give you both of those things Josh
Brolin brings a reality to the character
he is wearing that low-cut suit he's
wearing the motion capture cameras the
performance is coming through not only
in his gestures in his face but in his
eyes there's about 2,900 visual effects
shots in the movie we wanted to make it
as photographic as possible
and I think that that's the most
important part
you
what makes data so great as these
conviction this is the only solution
he's seen it firsthand on his planet
Titan was like most planets when we
faced extinction I offered a solution
genocide
what I predicted came to my house
congratulations you're a prophet under
survivor
Tony knows just by the way that Bruce
Banner describes Thanos it's a different
game now
he said Loki detect on New York that's
him
he is the biggest army in the universe
and he is not gonna stop this is sheer
force is something that none of the
Avengers has ever encountered before
Thanos has been inside my head for six
years so I say we take the fight to him
heroes are only as good as their villain
but the Avengers were built for anything
it's for stopping Santos from completing
his goal
[Music]
on really isn't something wanted to
citizen balancing the universe but this
does put a smile on my face
you